les salariés ne le savent peut-être pas
mais les grandes entreprises ont
l'obligation de mettre en place un plan
de déplacement les demandes sont
récurrente en fait entre les secteurs
c'est beaucoup au départ c'est des
demandes d'amélioration de l'offre de
transport collectif après on va sur les
modes alternatifs comme le vélo le
covoiturage la marche à pied et après on
va sur des questions beaucoup plus
larges sur les services qu'est-ce qu'il
y a comme service à proximité et au
final on travaille sur le logement parce
qu'en fait les questions de transport
amènent des questions de logement les
gens on des de transport parce qu'il
habit toujours plus loin pour des
questions de de contraintes immobilières
et donc on essaie de travailler avec les
entreprises sur les questions de
logement à 5 an en Yveline ce principe
concerne l'ensemble des sociétés grandes
comme petites une association aînée
Delta chargé de réfléchir à ces
questions elle regroupe une quarantaine
d'entreprises et couvre ainsi 50 % des
emplois du territoire l'enjeu est
environnemental et économique car un
territoire mieux desservi c'est un
territoire plus attractif sur un
territoire ça permet de péréniser une
implantation ça permet de continuer à
recruter et avec l'augmentation du coût
du carburant et cetera on se rend compte
qu'il est de plus en plus difficile de
faire venir des jeunes si ils doivent
faire l'acquisition d'une voiture faire
des kilomètres et à terme des
entreprises peuvent amener à réduire
leurs effectifs sur cette zone se
développer ailleurs dans des zones qui
auront plus d'attractivité donc il est
important de penser à long terme exemple
récent mise en place dans ce cadre de
Plan de Déplacement interentreprise la
refonde des lignes de bus skibus pour
mieux desservir la zone de Trapp et
encours seulement 15 % des salariés
travaillant à 50 ans en ivelin utilise
les transports en commun l'objectif que
ce pourcentage gagne un point par an